Speaker 1: Our correspondent Luke Beasley,
whose YouTube channel you can find it David
Pacman dot com slash Luke was there and he
spoke to a litany of Trump supporters we were
trying to figure out at this point this isn't
even the first indictment this is the second
indictment serious crimes, 37 felonies.
The indictment is extraordinarily detailed
and tight as Chris Christie and others have
referred to it, who is still defending this
guy?
And we got the answer.
And it is really, really scary.
Luke doing an incredible job.
The conspiracy theories that come out of the
mouths of the people still defending this
guy tell us a lot about the cultish nature
The cult members are the ones that are left.
Here are two young ladies with a wild conspiracy
theory.
They believe Trump is still president.
They are slurring badly, and they seem confused
by even what they are telling Luke.
Listen to this.
Speaker 4: What are your thoughts about the
arraignment?
Speaker 2: Candace?
We believe it's a witch hunt, but we do believe
that President Trump is actually protected
under the continuity of government.
I believe he's our authentic president and
that we are watching a movie.
Speaker 4: Oh, really?
So he's the current president of the United
States.
Speaker 2: I believe that.
Speaker 4: Like, what is Biden doing then?
Well, Biden is.
Speaker 2: It's we're under continuity of
government.
It's a military action.
Speaker 1: Okay.
So this is where this happens with every one
of these folks that Luke interviews.
As soon as you ask any follow up, they start
to look confused about what's coming out of
their own mouths.
That's the commonality, the common thread
between all of these.
Speaker 2: And so they're showing the people
in slow motion, the corruption and all the
different elements, all the different agencies
and the dual system.
So they're saying, okay, if you want to steal
the election, which they did, this is what
you're going to get.
Speaker 4: So then how is Biden doing in his
role?
Is he the president right now?
Speaker 2: Joe Biden is an actor.
I think Biden is.
He's been gone a long time.
I'm sorry.
Speaker 4: I'm gone.
Dead on.
Dead.
He's gone dead.
The one walking around an actor.
Do we know who the actor is.
Speaker 1: And why would they pick an actor
who looks frail and sometimes falls?
Right.
Like, why would you do that?
Speaker 2: There is different ones that play
him.
Everybody has actors, but I know it sounds
so far fetched, but yeah, they say that they're
going to reveal it soon.
Speaker 1: They say Chicken.
Whose day, by the way, they're going to reveal
it is.
Speaker 2: Is, is, is protecting we the people.
I do believe he's actually that king.
It sounds pretty crazy.
Instead of Make America Great Again, it's
going to be Make the Earth great again.
Speaker 1: Right?
And for those of you who thought that George
Washington decided that the US would not have
kings, I guess you were wrong.
I guess Trump is actually king right now.
If you're wondering why they aren't abandoning
Trump based on what is going on, this is why
these are the people that are still defending
this guy.
Here's another guy Luke spoke to.
This guy has COVID conspiracies.
A woman walks over and warns the guy that
Luke is on the left and then the guy demands
Fauci be killed.
This is very serious stuff.
These are sick, sick people.
Speaker 2: Oh, Kobe, there's the government
made virus.
Yeah.
Yeah, it's a government made virus.
Oh, that's what.
Speaker 1: The woman says.
This guy's a total liberal.
He's probably going to change what you say.
And of course, as you can see, we are playing
it uninterrupted.
No edits, no cuts.
It's like this stuff these people don't get.
This stuff is so crazy.
Why on earth would we added it?
There's no way to edit it to make it crazier.
Speaker 2: Yeah, of course we can talk to
liberals.
Yes.
If the government made viruses didn't came
from a lab.
If it came from a lab, it is a it's a weapon
of bio warfare and then they follow it up.
This is a deep population operation that they're
doing.
Speaker 4: My audience is less familiar, so
we got to walk through step by step a D.
Speaker 1: By the way, a D population operation
with a virus that kills 0.6% of the people
it infects.
That's what this guy's alleging.
Speaker 4: Facilitated the creating of the
virus.
And for what purpose?
Speaker 2: It's a deep state.
It's the globalist Bill Gates, the World Economic
Forum, Klaus Schwab, The game from Davos.
This has been in the works for a long time.
Speaker 4: Was The Cove, in an effort to get
Trump out of office.
Speaker 1: I think I.
Speaker 2: Think in part in combination they've
been planning.
If you listen to Dr. Fauci, Fauji, before
he even entered office, said that he's going
to have to default.
Speaker 1: What is wrong with these people
fault with the pandemic?
Speaker 2: They've been planning this for
a long time.
Speaker 4: He said, I'm going to have to deal
with the quote unquote, pandemic.
Speaker 2: He didn't say a pandemic, but he
said there's going to be a pandemic on his
watch.
Speaker 4: And there are people have been
predicting he's been working for decades.
Speaker 2: Oh, yeah, he he you know what?
And the apology needs to be locked up.
And you should be hanging from a tree.
Speaker 1: Hanging from a tree?
The we wonder why the indictment doesn't change
their minds about Trump.
And he says felt she should be hanging from
a tree.
Same guy also says the FBI did January 6th.
These are the people still supporting Trump.
Speaker 2: I was there January six.
January.
Speaker 1: That's that's not a shocker.
Speaker 2: Six was a set up by the FBI and
the CIA.
The CIA and the FBI.
Speaker 4: It's corrupt.
That's interesting.
So why would the FBI, I'm guessing, to help
Democrats did that?
Oh, yeah.
So then why would the FBI, in consultation
with their coordination with the Democrats,
want to stop the certification of Biden's
win?
Speaker 2: Oh, they didn't stop the certification
of Biden's win.
They were for Biden's win.
The FBI and the CIA are corrupt.
They were behind the whole right.
We got stolen by.
Speaker 1: The FBI and CIA.
In order to help Biden organized a riot to
try to hurt Biden.
Why don't you guys understand this?
It's so obvious.
Speaker 4: We can't jump from the lily pad
a little bit.
So focusing in on January 6th, why would the
FBI want to create January 6th and frame Trump
supporters?
Speaker 2: All because they wanted to make
us look like we're white supremacists.
They want us to lock us up.
There is half of the January six people that
are in the DC Gulag.
Speaker 1: Gulag?
Okay.
This is sickness.
We have to just say this is not people saying,
hey, you know, I want to engage in the political
system, so I'm going to evaluate the political
positions of the candidates and make a decision.
This that's not what's going on.
Okay.
Luke actually randomly came across a sort
of well-known I think he goes he's called
a MAGA rapper.
His name is Forgy Otto Blow.
I don't know if that's a given name or a nickname
for Giotto.
Below says he has a whole new song about what's
happening at Target, which he doesn't seem
to actually understand.
Luke tries to explain it to him.
Speaker 4: I'm here with Foreshadow Blue,
and you recently released a song, right, about
Target?
Speaker 2: Yeah.
Boycott Target one number one a lot.
Some charts.
Pretty cool stuff.
Speaker 4: Yeah.
And what motivated you to write that song?
Speaker 2: And pretty much the evil agenda
there.
Push it on these children.
Right.
So as I was telling the man before, it's not
like an anti-gay song.
You know, it's an anti putting children brand
clothes with bathing suits where you could
have tuck your genitals in.
Speaker 4: But they didn't do that.
Right.
Target did do that.
No, that's been like about.
Speaker 1: 30 And on screen right now there
are all sorts of articles debunking the idea
of touch friendly clothing for kids.
Like not that this guy cares, but it's been
widely debunked.
Luke is completely correct.
Speaker 2: And it's now been debunked.
I've been in target.
I hold the held it up for adults.
No, there's a children's site you want to
see right now.
My stuff.
Speaker 4: I promise that that's only in adult
sizes.
Speaker 2: And adult sizes.
You want to see the children's stuff?
Speaker 1: I have it.
Yeah.
Remember, the claim was tuck up tucking things
for children.
Speaker 3: At the children clothes.
Speaker 2: My guy celebrating Pride Month.
These are children.
Clothes.
These is just.
Speaker 1: Like a shirt, by the way.
Speaker 4: You told me.
Tuck it.
Speaker 2: No.
All the pride clothes.
You think any.
Speaker 4: Pride clothes are bad?
Telling a child, Hey, whoever you.
Speaker 2: Are, the kid should be wearing
a shirt.
And you say, My man, I read my kid in third
grade needs we wearing a shirt.
This is treated like matter.
Speaker 1: Okay, so first the claim was that
they have tuck clothes for kids to tuck genitalia.
Now it's just something that says trans Lives
matter, which, of course, was not the original
claim that that that 4G auto blow made.
Then we go to a woman who seems truly sick.
She gets extremely close to look super, super
close.
And she seems to be warning him about something.
It's hard for me to tell you what she's warning
Luke about, but it is a warning that.
Speaker 2: Communism I don't.
Unidentified: Know why they are going to eliminate
you.
Do that one more day today, your desire.
You're going to see.
Speaker 2: That we get why I'm anti-gun.
That's why they want to finish their why I'm
hitting.
I need the last one in the lead.
Speaker 1: I guess she's telling Luke that
because he's white.
The left.
The left is going to do something bad to him.
Speaker 2: Bombing is bombing, I think.
I do think.
Yeah, because this guy, they.
Speaker 4: Might have to fight and I guess.
Speaker 2: They want to eliminate.
Speaker 4: What makes you believe.
Speaker 2: That when you're going into your
office on that goes to the university.
Speaker 1: She has a song that will explain
it.
Speaker 2: You're going to register in the
university.
He's the laughing, the least you go he's he
looks like you and their last name.
And I have to ask for just one more detail
that you laugh.
I have already like an x ray.
Speaker 4: The items older than you that he's
wiser than, you.
Speaker 2: Know, no age old me and think,
Oh.
Speaker 1: Okay.
Shit, this woman is wiser than Luke because
she's older.
But Biden, even though he's older than this
woman, is not wiser because he's sick.
Speaker 2: The time and it's.
Speaker 4: A democratic.
Speaker 2: Baby.
I don't know that.
It's a shame.
It's a shame that he's the representation
of this country, he said.
Boy, percentage on the whole God, the whole
why there is bad.
Oh, he said, weak.
Imagine so.
Speaker 1: All right.
So.
So this is you know, these are the folks that
are supporting him now.
And we're like, oh, maybe they'll change their
mind.
Wow.
Last one.
Okay.
Here's a woman who says that Obama is actually
running the country right now.
Speaker 2: Obama now.
Speaker 1: And he's running it in a racist
way.
I don't know.
Speaker 4: Is Obama's racist?
Speaker 2: Racist?
Are you kidding me?
Look, what he's doing is anti black.
You think Biden is running the country now?
Are you kidding me?
Speaker 4: So Obama's.
Speaker 1: Biden.
It's funny how some of these people say it's
really Trump running the country.
Others say it's really Obama.
It would be great to get them together to
argue about who's actually running the country.
Speaker 5: Oh, God.
I recently was a head of the KKK for a while,
and Biden actually applauded him.
Speaker 4: Right.
So but the Obama part is interesting to me.
So Obama is running the country.
So how in what capacity?
Speaker 2: He's you know, he's doing what
he said he wanted to do six years ago.
He said I'd be happy running the government
from my basement, and that's what he's doing.
You don't think Biden is, do you?
Speaker 4: I happen to.
Yeah.
Speaker 2: You think that man is making any
decisions?
He doesn't even know what day it is.
Speaker 1: That's literally a quote from Trump
verbatim.
Speaker 2: Of him so medicated.
No, I'm sorry.
He's like my father.
Yeah, he's got it.
It's it's it's it's a joke.
And let me tell you something else.
This the last thing I want to say.
If you own the mainstream media, you can do
anything you want to because you're keeping
the truth from the.
Speaker 4: People who owns the mainstream
media, liberals.
Speaker 2: Liberal Jews.
And I'm.
Speaker 1: Oh, no.
Speaker 2: No.
I'm a Jewish guy.
I'm a Jewish girl.
So I can say that.
Okay.
My people are destroying this country.
They run the Democrat Party.
They run Hollywood.
They run the education system.
Are you kidding me?
Speaker 4: You mentioned that Obama is racist
because of what he's doing in power right
now.
What is he doing this racist.
Speaker 2: For America for?
Speaker 4: But what's the racist part of it?
Speaker 2: Look what he's.
Speaker 1: Well, he's black.
Luke.
Isn't that racist enough?
Speaker 2: Going to the gay community.
You don't think what he's doing is hurting
them?
Speaker 4: But homosexuality is not a race,
right?
Speaker 2: It's not.
Oh, no, no.
I'm talking.
I'm jumping.
I'm jumping around.
You got to.
Speaker 1: We can tell you're jumping around
mem on me.
Speaker 2: I'm with you.
The racism in this country started with Obama.
Oh, you know, black and white.
Speaker 1: So listen, Luke doing the best
he can.
It's sort of like if I hand you a rotten banana
and some blades of grass and tell you to make
beef Wellington or a nice Hanukkah brisket,
you're going to struggle because I'm not giving
you the right material.
Luke Doing the absolute best he can with some
really rotten material.
Make sure you're subscribed to Luke's channel.
David Packman, dot com slash Luke.
Make sure you're subscribed to this channel.
We will continue to be on the ground.
To the extent people want us to do it.
We will continue to be on the ground throughout
the 2024 primary and election.
All I ask of you is make sure that you're
subscribed to our audio podcast or hit that
subscribe button on YouTube.
Let's take a break, catch our breath collectively,
see if we can recover from that, and then
we will continue.